this is a production of cornell
university yeah
welcome everybody this is the 13th
episode of our spring series the cornell
turf show
fastest 30 minutes in terp we've been
keeping it condensed and getting you
guys all the information in a timely fa
in a timely manner here for the
springtime our guest today is going to
be dr leah brillman of dlf pixie
real seat guru we're excited to talk
about bent grass seed in the springtime
a topic of conversation whenever we get
around with superintendents in our
northeast region here
but as always we'll get started today
with uh frank rossi a little overview of
our last week you know frank it seems
like every time we
we do one of these webinars on thursday
and friday we've got snow out for
whatever reason
uh so we've really had these uh stops
and starts to the fall
um i'm sure you'll talk about that in a
little bit but as always you got a cool
little image here
bring it bring your house to work it
looks like yeah that's right
and and you know whether it's uh
bringing your
pal to work uh in the shop or bringing
your kid to golf
uh i we have a former employee and
colleague who uh
took a picture of this on the golf
course and said carl this is gonna be
you pretty soon
uh with the stroller out there and the
kid practicing uh
your putting so so uh always a good way
to start the equipment
is starting to show up uh on golf
courses where
everybody's uh bragging on their big
stuff and a big old mower
uh like that always makes a a golf guy
all happy
and of course uh leah in the northeast
girl we're starting to rip it up
uh this is a pretty standard scene
around
a lot of the golf courses which is i
have to say a bit funny to me sometimes
because i feel like sometimes like on
the bottom left here you see a picture
that steve cook
uh tweeted from edina and i've been on
those greens and i can tell you
sometimes they look
absolutely perfect and you wonder what
the hell are they doing this for they're
absolutely perfect and they're making a
mess of them so listen
carl before we get into our little
weather update and a little chat with
leah
why don't you start a little bit with
the tip of the day and remind everybody
this is brought to you by our project
with the rochester institute of
technology the environmental results
program that's
focused on improving uh bmp adoption
uh in new york state particularly west
of i-81 um
there's a website you can go to to learn
more and and carl's got a poster
uh that he uh received in the mail that
everybody who's part of this west of
i-81 should have gotten in the golf
business if you didn't
reach out to carl and if you'd like one
you can go to that website and grab one
and so carl
the topic for today is spot treating but
you know because we were struggling
a bit to know what kind of conversation
we'd have we probably would throw in
uh selecting good varieties as well but
let's talk about spot treating today
yeah so you know one one of the aims of
this poster is of course create
awareness
of best management practices to reduce
our resource use and spot treating
is probably the best way you're going to
get to reducing
pesticide use this also could be applied
to fertilizer you see in our poster it's
on a pest section but
really applying pesticides only only to
the places you need them so
we actually saw a recent article in the
usj green section
this is from superintendent andrew
jorgensen
down there in ocala florida and they
have a problem i think it's pine
pine needle grubs or a certain insect
pest
and what he's got is a real simple
solution instead of applying that
insecticide to the entire property
when he's out there scouting he's got
his utility car in a
and a spreader just a small spreader on
the back of the of that cart
whenever he sees uh grubs whenever he
scouts in a certain area he can just
apply
only the amount that's necessary instead
of going across you know
20 30 acres of fairway or rough area
and another reason to spot treat it you
know we see this out in
wisconsin madison paul koch is partnered
with the folks at the university ridge
golf course there
and putting weather stations on two
different fairways and seeing that
consistently one
fairway is 15 lower in the smith
currents dollar spot
pressure than another area and what does
that say you know that could be the
difference between
treating that ninth fairway uh you know
two or three times
less over the course of the year than a
that 18th fairway so again reducing our
acreage that we're treating
lowering those the overall pesticide use
and of course that lowers your budget
and the labor time to spray these areas
too so being a little bit more strategic
in these spot treatment methods when
we're thinking about pesticides we've
talked about this with fertilizer and
and growth rate earlier in our spring
series but
just a really excellent way to reduce
your pesticide use and be really
targeted
and no doubt carl because you know we
really have the technology there both to
collect the data
and to make the application right so
let's start out with
some of the weather data that drives
some of the decisions that we're making
and this tends to be
a popular conversation um among golf
course superintendents at this time for
root pathogens as we've talked about we
had john johnny inguinado with us a
couple of weeks ago
talking about root pathogens and timing
it for soil temperatures and
making effective applications and you
can see when you get down into the
metropolitan new york area
we're getting pretty warm soils now i
think they're pretty good uh estimation
that we're going to stall a little bit
for the weekend uh but soon uh
start to see warming up and and our our
weather guru arte gaitano on the
conference call this morning
uh said clearly that we can put a fork
in the winter and we're going to hold
them to that
uh after this coming weekend we should
be done with it
uh and turning the corner and warming up
moving on forward now
the interesting thing about the season
so far is uh just this last week we got
a nice patch of rainfall
and it mostly fell where it was needed
the most if you look at the drought map
on the right
you can see the uh the la southeastern
new england
and massachusetts uh up into vermont
now new hampshire and maine not so much
but certainly a little that
you know up up the connecticut river
valley and along the coast by the cape
long island got some rain uh this helped
some of the drier areas
uh that are already happening throughout
the northeast
now the other thing you're gonna notice
uh as
is what something we talked about again
this morning on our conference call is
how the growing season now stalls and
how this
sort of give informs us about the things
we
target you know uh one thing for example
is uh crabgrass emergence and forsythia
bloom
you know rich buckley was talking this
morning with us saying you know i got
half green half gold out
you know near my house uh and i think
i'm starting to see uh the growing
degree day model is indicating
that the annual bluegrass weevil adults
should be moving and wondering if people
are looking
you know we're quite a bit ahead last
week
and now it looks like we're getting
close to normal and you know you can
accumulate quite a bit of degree days
uh in one day uh in the spring so you
want to be careful
get out there keep looking it's good to
have the data but
it's also good to go take a look well
speaking of having to take a look there
was one particular thing that rich
mentioned this morning that
seemed to be coming into the lab a
little bit more than normal and i think
you could say it has something to do
with the slow growth rate and that is
brown ring patch or white tia
right the waitia patch that's come on
and become you know a lot of people
think
a cosmetic problem for the most part but
when you look at the ridges of this
particular pathogen
you can see in many cases let me just
draw a little
let me get my pen here and you can see
right along for those of you watching
live or watching the recording for those
of you on the podcast
i can't help you with this sometimes but
we think we still want you to hear this
when you look along the edge of the ring
sometimes you'll see
pitting you can almost see it in this
one picture here where it starts to
really decline gets a little pitted and
can affect ball roll a little bit
so obviously top dressing can help with
this because the grass will recover from
it
and some of the issue is related to the
slowing of growth you know whether
you're slowing of growth because you're
drier
or you're slowing of growth because
you're cooler the waitia patch on
putting green seems to be
increasing now the way to approach this
from my perspective
is first uh you know decide well with
warm weather coming and
you know maybe my growth regulators are
wearing off and obviously your growth
regulator program
could be impacting this because slower
growing
uh plants are going to have a bigger
problem with this you can go to the uw
website which has this really nice uh it
basically takes the uh
you know the uh turfgrass diseases
thing that's come from uh pulvinselli at
kentucky
and now bruce clark and paul uh are
involved
involved in this and and it's online so
you can type in brown ring patch
and get this particular uh web go to
this particular website
type in brown ring patch and you get a
collection of products that
that provide control now i looked at
this in in the publication itself
and what i noticed from looking through
here you know three is
you know there's efficacy right it means
it's pretty good it's been shown in
research
uh but the a uh uh superscript indicates
a lot of these are two double e values
so you know they work and they're
special labels for your state you can
write a
a two double e exemption for some
products if they
show efficacy but it's not necessarily
on the label and of course this
applies uh federally as well as as
particularly here in new york state
but one of the one of the products i
want to draw your attention to is a firm
or polyoxin we've had a very effective
control with this and i think andy
wilson would say that
uh from some of our work at beth uh
we've had really good effective control
with that product
but the other thing i want to draw your
attention to is when you get into these
combination products
right you may have a product that has
some efficacy
you know efficacy by itself but then you
know
is it in the combination at the same
rate make sure you're looking at some of
these things
if you choose if you choose to make an
application
for this particular package okay so the
topic for today and i'm gonna set you
up uh i'm gonna set you up lee as good
as i can do it right we're gonna
talk about bent grass and i'm gonna
bring up traffic tolerance
i'm gonna bring up you know the pressure
that golf is under this is rounds of
golf
after the pandemic you can see year over
year
month of month month to month we were
seeing big big
surges uh in uh play
throughout the country and i think you
know this as well as i do that
play is relentless right you start to
see where
play gets focused on putting greens
right around the cup
and then this is and i flew through that
but now i'll go a little slower right
this is the
growth rate uh you know proposed
by uh turgeon and vargas a number of
years ago
uh you know in their po annual book and
at the same time
they suggest a growth uh cycle
like this for creeping bent grass and
you know it suggests that it
you know comes on you know these are a
little bit disjointed here but
essentially
this is suggesting that grow active grow
top growth anyway doesn't really ensue
on the bank grasses until
much later in the spring certainly
compared
to pola annual now leah carl's been
playing around with this in our research
program
with dave hicks our golf course
superintendent here at cornell
and we took a shaded green that was a
lot of annual bluegrass
and compared it to a wide open green
that had a lot more creeping bent grass
and we were collecting clippings
throughout the year and rather than
trust that you know prescribed growth
cycle
you know carl uh and dave and the staff
were collecting clippings
and the blue line here is the po
annual green and the red line here uh
is the creeping bank grass screen and so
you can see there clearly
are times uh when you get a little more
growth
uh than others but it also doesn't seem
to follow the exact
uh pattern that they showed uh in those
graphics leah so
so we measure these things we do see
some advantage
to annual bluegrass at certain times and
we also see some advantage to
uh creeping bank grasses what cultivars
okay yeah yeah these are really old ben
poe greens
you set me up perfectly yeah because now
it becomes a broader discussion right
and i'm
just showing this picture to show and
say there are very big differences
between these cultivars and i didn't
pick any of these pictures with any
particular intent involved
just to say as you just said
cultivars make a difference and i want
to draw attention to this
not just for putting greens leah but
carl has been thinking about this a lot
for fairway
selection about uh bent grass resist you
know
dollar spot resistant varieties and the
value that they can bring
uh to an operation and so if you look at
the smith kern's model carl took the
data and put it out over
nine growing seasons and you set their
threshold of 20 percent
where you start to have to worry or
might probably trigger your spraying
for dollar spot and then you say well if
i got a resistant variety
maybe i don't see dollar spot until it's
about 40
on the smith currents model and i think
james hempling might have done and you
may be privy to some of this
they might have done some of this work
at rutgers with some of these varieties
with the smith and they're they're doing
more
and um using threshold models
you having a dollar spot resistant
variety
in some years you could reduce the
number of sprays you needed
by well say you only needed
three sprays on a threshold or one spray
on a threshold where you needed nine
on a re on a susceptible variety so
it really does in it and it is most
important on a fairway bent grass
that's where you're gonna really you
really need it you
you should always ask that first before
you select
a bent grasp for a fairway is how
resistant is it to dollar spot
yeah and thank you for saying that
because for those of you watching
the video or live you know you see this
graph of nine years
and there are in fact if you have a 40
threshold
there are at least two years here where
you wouldn't need to treat uh at all so
what you're saying you know that that's
exactly what we're talking about leah
and then you know somebody so so there's
some of these really positive things
right
but then there's these ideas well you
gotta fuss with them
you know because they get leggy and
maybe they park up this is some of our
traffic work
uh that we've done with golf shoes where
we've you know you twist and turn
around the cup and you see the bent
grass respond
and of course you know the early spring
growth conditions leah
uh is something that you know this is uh
tommy
tommy witt's place in chicago with a
beautiful bent grass fairway there
and so here's the questions for today
kid let's start with traffic tolerance
you know i showed those things early
those those slides earlier
that um that showed potential growth
rate we don't have to look at the pick
questions i'll bring them up as we go
um what do you say when people say well
you know
i get a lot of spring golf um i i can't
you know i don't know how to have a bent
grass fairway or bent grass green
because i get too much traffic how do
you answer that
to start well i don't know about other
bent grass breeders but me and then
working i've been working
first when i was working but also
working a lot with rutgers university
was we found we were losing the battle
with bent grass more in the spring and
the fall
than we were in the summer and you know
originally
they started talking about we needed
more heat tolerance
in um bent grasses well it was sean
emerson
who said no i don't need more heat
tolerance the heat tolerance is fine
what i need is more spring and fall
growth because we need that to take the
golfers
and we need that to compete with the po
annua
so i started i switched a lot of the
bent grass breeding
and our emphasis became besides
dollar spot because we threw anything
away that got significant dollar spot
was spring and fall growth because that
was when we were losing the battle
with um with po annua
so for instance we've also been having
talks with chris tritterbaugh of
hazeltine
and um he's got some trials there and
um we've been debating how best to
measure this
especially in cool temperature areas you
know how do i go out
and select for that particular thing
and so he and i have an idea and we've
been comparing notes for a couple years
on when you first see dew on the bent
grass
is when we think it may be actively
growing so it may enable us to put
bent grass up far north and find the
ones that actually
show that do first thing to select for
that spring growth that spring green up
so he noticed that one of our
newer cultivars mcdonald he had it
showing not only was it growing later in
the fall for him
in his in his trials it actually was
coming on
and it was showing do two weeks or more
earlier than some of the other bent
grasses he had in the trial
so it's we've learned that's what we
have to do
and that is one of our emphasis and has
been for 20 years
is to try and get those saddle um
conditions
for um creeping bent grass so we can
compete with poa
so even if you do that leah even if you
do that and get early spring growth
and you even get in periods where bank
grass grows well
is it your opinion that there is a limit
to traffic with bank grass where
you're it's too much traffic for bent
grass
not in the newest cultivars okay
and part of it is um we've also been
um working with um rutgers to put wear
machines
across those trials and so
you can't anytime you're a breeder of
bent grass or any
species you have to be thinking of
multiple things at the same time so we
put ware machines across those so we
look for those
that the clones to put in our new
cultivars
that also responded well in both fairway
trials
and in greens trials to the wear
machines and we didn't lose
cover with those wear machines when they
put it on
so i really think the newer material
will take the wear it'll grow in the
spring and fall
and but that's not every new cultivar
it's ones that have been looked at
intensively
and only you know and you throw out 90
of the material in the long term and
even when you think you've got a success
sometimes something else shows up and it
may not work
and so let me let me feed on that
because you know our pal dan dinelli who
we love and adore
uh at north shores probably taught us
both a little bit about
bank grass management and bank grass
cultivar selection
he talks a lot about segregation and you
and i are on that little text chain that
we keep with mike fadanza and some of
these other people
and this came up about you know when
you're building a bent grass variety
you're using different
clones to put them together and then you
get that segregation
can you talk about anything we know
about how that
level of segregation potentially impacts
performance because
it sounds to me like well you could have
some that are some
clones that are good for early spring
and then some that are better for
traffic tolerance long term
and maybe that's where the segregation
comes from and
is that good or bad and i guess i need
you to ask me about
answer me about segregation in general
okay segregation in general we used to
see it a lot more and most people think
about
what they would see with pin cross the
segregation
into the essentially you could see those
three clones that made the
cross the original cross to it and you
had the one that always purpled
you had the one that grew this way and
um
that would do it and as we develop bent
grasses and it's through multiple
multiple cycles
of selection we've selected against that
segregation we've tried to make those
all those clones perform very similarly
look very similar in appearance um
and i will tell you i would say every
generation we've gotten better
so the current i would say the ones that
were in the last intact
and the ones that are prop i don't know
all of them in the current ones but the
ones we've been dealing with
um i know i walked every single one of
those breeder blocks
to make them 100 uniform i also got out
and walked in those foundation fields to
make sure we didn't see
anything that looked at all different
and because
the clones we've been selecting for 20
years for ones that looked
most similar to each other and we're
very carefully at each stage of the line
i won't say you won't see zero but say
20 years ago the ones i created you
maybe
saw point one percent
and point one percent in creeping bent
grass
if you've got six million seeds per
pound
that can be a lot of potential plants
and even if most of them don't get
established
you would still see occasional
segregates
in the last 10 years um
007 great variety probably one of the
most adaptable varieties
we've ever released um grown everywhere
we still see an occasional plant that
will
show up for us okay that's a little
different in growth habit
but this latest generation i would say
we don't see them we have yet to see any
segregation in them
so how excited are you about
the prospect of polacure
let's say everybody learns how to use it
right
it eliminates a lot of the pressure
that you guys have selected for a little
bit but i wonder if it doesn't
potentially create other problems i
wonder if sometimes
you know having the poet creep in
teaches us well maybe you gotta not have
that
where are you at with and i'm sure
you're in many ways thinking about this
because the potential for you to
sell a lot of bent grass seed uh with
the idea that polar cure fused properly
is a
potentially sustainable way with other
growth regulators and other things
of not having annual bluegrass problems
how does that really shift or change any
of your thinking where you're having
poetry on the market
well we we actually we have a bent grass
advisory group and we talked to a lot of
them about
poetcure some of them are currently
using it
and have used it for many years
especially in very
high power pressure areas along the
coast of
california some of these areas
we've got others who played with it
and they decided for instance they like
trim it just as well or better
um and they consistently use it
one of the things i think is important
that we have at least two things to
depend upon so poe cure and trim it
now i was running figures the other day
because we were asking about
um we had gotten the thing from golf
course industry that showed
you know the power cure ad and we we
were looking at the cost
and we were thinking about fairway
applications okay
so we actually went through the whole
numbers and what i came up with on their
rate for fairway is each app was
um about 850 dollars per acre
okay each application of poetry so i ran
the numbers the other day just because
i was semi-curious what it would come to
i don't know how many people are and
then they say one to six apps and you
kind of roll your eyes right
um so um greens i definitely think it
will help
and i think we do have to remember we do
need to use rotations
because if i also on the advisory with
some of the poe
um and we know polo will adapt
given an opportunity we know this about
roy annually that's right
that's right all right so listen thank
you for mentioning
fairways and that's where i want to wrap
up because there's a running argument
underway here at cornell
about the right fairway grass and i
couldn't let you get away
and i know we've been talking about
bankruptcy and i you know
and and i know that maybe everything
else is second rate in other people's
minds but i'd like to hear from you
if you don't have a lot of resources if
you
might have irrigation but you don't
really want to have to rely on it
you know if you have a a lot of traffic
uh
on your fairways uh or maybe not much
traffic on your favorites maybe you have
heavy soils
that even if you don't fertilize the
grass grows a lot
um i'm putting you on the spot there
leah
um is bent grass always the right choice
for fairways and if it's not what's your
second choice
i don't know if bent grass is always the
right choice i mean
um especially under certain environments
kentucky bluegrass if you choose the
right ones
and part of them is people were
convinced they
they had to get these ones that are
actually midnight types which were again
non-competitive against pro
annual so you need ones that
kentucky bluegrass is that again early
spring green up
late fall growth with good wear
tolerance
um decent drought tolerance they can
give you
a pretty good solution most sites
especially a heavy soil fine fescues may
not be a good choice for a heavy soil
in spite of what people will try and
tell you
um but then we also need to think about
maybe fine fescue bluegrass blends we've
done some interesting ones with those
um even fine fescues with creepy mint
grass
what about colonial what about what
about fine fescue colonial or you're
still worried about brown patch with
colonials well yes and the problem is
we've had
very high issues and so has the entire
industry
we're having a hard time getting
colonial bent grasses actually produced
because there are only a certain number
true colonials not highland
because there are only a certain number
of growers and we've lost a lot of those
acres so it's becoming
a very significant um
thing on getting colonial bent grasses
we're struggling right now
every company is or we lost our last
field
two years ago have not been able to
replace it
we don't even have um um
velvet been grass is another one we
cannot get produced right now well i'll
tell you leah
we will save the state of the seed
industry for another
day i'll get you on the long podcast
we'll do a long conversation
about the status of the seed industry
that i think
no matter what part of the grass
business you're in as i understand it
leah
seed supplies are going to be tricky uh
and prices are going up
because of what you said there seems to
be
a more difficult time to get people to
grow
some of these niche uh plants i mean you
know maybe
even ryegrass that a lot of people grow
i believe you guys are saying
with the winter and the early spring
cold maybe that's impacted the harvest
there as well
well and the big thing is we had huge
demand for grass seed last year
who knew everybody wanted to plant grass
during the middle of a pandemic
and um who figured who knew that
that's right um it's going to be a
struggle this year to get
um crop in and crop is it's going to be
an inter
it's quite retapped a long time
yesterday it's going to be an
interesting fall
may you live in interesting times that's
exactly
right and carl what could be more
interesting than a
thursday morning conversation with leah
brillman let me know carl what is
no nothing is and that's why it's the
fastest 30 minutes in turk right
it goes by before you even know it again
we're breaking the space time continuum
here
uh disobeying the laws of physics but uh
you know thank you thanks again leah
for coming on talking about seed um you
know again
we've highlighted this bmp tips of the
day uh really using the new varieties
you talk so much about
today there's a lot of work that goes in
that and it's been a real cost effective
way to
to reduce resource use and to improve
conditions on
golf courses uh all across the nation so
uh you know with that
we'll get everybody out of here thanks
everybody for listening tomorrow's guest
chase straw we'll have him on to talk
about precision sports field management
that'll be an interesting conversation
but uh until then we'll see you guys
next uh next time this has been a
production of cornell university
on the web at cornell.edu